one of the things you want to do with
the conception like true passion is you
actually want to start thinking about it
like a psychologist or like a scientist
because compassion is actually definable
and it I think the easiest way to
approach it is to think about it in big
five terms because it Maps are
incredible and especially you can break
the variable of felonies compassion and
politeness and the liberal types
especially the social justice types are
way higher in compassion it's actually
their their fundamental characteristic
and you might think well compassion is
is a virtue it's like yeah it is a
virtue but any other dimensional version
immediately becomes a vice because real
virtue is the intermingling of a number
of virtues and they're and they're
integrated into a functional identity
that can be expressed socially and
compassion compassion is great if you
happen to be the entity towards which it
is directed but compassion tends to
divide the world into crying children
and predatory snakes right and so if
you're a French RLJ great man but if you
happen to be identified as one of the
predatory snakes you better look the
hell out and so you know capacity is
what the mother grizzly bear feels for
her cubs when she eats you because he's
going in the way right exactly so you
don't want to be thinking for a second
that compassion isn't a virtue that
could lead to violence because it
certainly can and the other problem with
compassion this is why we have
conscientiousness right there's bias
canonical personality dimensions
agreeable justice particularly if you're
dealing again in a kin system you want
to distribute resources equally for
example among your children if you want
to omit to have not only the same chance
you even want them roughly to have
same outcome a good one but the problem
is that you can't extend that moral
network to larger groups not as far as I
can tell you need conscientiousness
which is a much colder version and it's
also a virgin's that much more
conservative large restructures over the
longer period of time so and you can
think about conscientiousness is a form
of compassion Genesis strange for me
play straight the hell out and work hard
and your life can go well it's like I
don't care how you're feeling how you
feel about that right now and like
someone who's cold low in agreement
let's say and high in conscientiousness
that's what they'll tell you every time
don't don't come whining to me I don't
care about your herd feeling do your
goddamn job or you could be able to the
street they call that person speak
really hard or like not at the service
they might have your long-term best
interest in mind and you're fortunate if
you come across someone who's like not
tragically disagreeable but moderately
disagreeable and I'm conscientious
that's can the Whitney into shape and
that's really helpful I mean you'll
admire people like that you will be able
to help you know and you think oh well
this person's actually gives me good
information even though you feel like a
slug after you after they've taken you
apart so okay so that's the compassion
issues like you can't just transform
that into a political stance and I think
part of what we're seeing is actually
the rise of a form of female
totalitarianism we have no idea what
totalitarianism would be like if women
read because that's never happened
before in history in class and so we've
introduced women into the political
sphere radically over the last 50 years
we have no idea what the consequence of
that is going to be but we do know from
our research which is preliminary that
agreeableness really predicts political
correctness but female gender makes over
and above the personality treason that's
something we found very rarely in our
research usually the text differences
are wiped out by the personality news
but not in secret
amazing on webinar getting merrier later
and they're having children much later
and they're having fewer of them and so
you also have to wonder what their
feminine orientation is doing with
itself in the interim roughly speaking
and large is being expressed as
political opinion like it's fair an
optional that's that's fine but it's not
fine when it starts to shut down
discussion